am lautesten gegen schuld trommel
natürlich der arbeitgeber lobby fein
initiative neue soziale marktwirtschaft
mit anzeigen die dieser ganzseitig
richtig teuer
er stand dann lieber martin erinnerst du
dich noch wie schlimm das damals war vor
der agenda
und diese niedriglöhner die sind gar
nicht unter bezahlt die sind flexibel
etwas gutes ohne den gelb unserer tollen
wohlstand gar nicht allerhöchste zeit
nicht mal zu bedanken
hallo liebe reinigungskraft mit
befristetem vertrag ja du bist
enttäuscht weil du trotz vollzeitjob
aufstocken muss sei doch einfach dankbar
dass du ein teil geborener zum
deutschlandstart teil bleiben von dial
haben hat kameras gesagt du bist die
stütze der gesellschaft weshalb kriegst
du ja auch stütze sei also weiter so
bleibt flexibel mobil und belastbar
damit das nicht
machen du machst das was du tust class
gibt auf mich schade das du nicht dabei
sein kann
keine initiative neue soziale
[Applaus]